y yo
funeral para despedir a decenas de
víctimas integrantes de la comunidad
chiíta en kandahar al sur de afganistán
entierran a familiares y amigos que
murieron en el más reciente atentado del
autodenominado estado islámico en esta
nación de la crisis beta zeidán estamos
enterrando a 63 integrantes inocentes de
la comunidad chiíta que fueron
martirizados ayer durante las oraciones
del viernes se pueden ver todas estas
cosas
que muchos otros han perdido partes del
cuerpo y de los que están en el hospital
en condiciones graves no se sabe cuántos
se sumarán el viernes el grupo yihadista
se adjudicó la autoría del atentado en
una mezquita chiita el grupo aseguró en
un comunicado que dos de sus integrantes
dispararon contra los guardias del
recinto y luego un atacante suicida
detonó un explosivo en la puerta otro lo
hizo dentro del templo los talibanes que
tomaron el poder del país en agosto
prometieron dar con los culpables
estamos haciendo todo lo posible para
detener a todos los responsables de la
explosión lo estamos investigando pero
no hemos detenido a nadie hasta ahora
hemos visto las cámaras de seguridad y
nuestros compañeros han recibido
instrucciones si dios quiere los
arrestaremos sin embargo los ataques del
estado islámico que ha ido expandiendo
sus ofensivas hacia el norte del país
levantan dudas sobre la capacidad de los
talibanes de hacer frente a la constante
amenaza terrorista la masacre del
viernes fue la más mortífera en el país
desde otro ataque suicida que mató a
decenas de personas en el aeropuerto de
kabul durante la caótica salida de las
tropas occidentales de afganistán